the times has published a pretty damning
report
alleging that the duchess bullied two
members of staff
out of kensington palace shortly after
the royal wedding in 2018
and made the life of another aide almost
unbearable this prompted the then head
of communications jason canal
to write an email outlining um the
duchess's
behavior and the alleged bullying in an
email to williams
then private secretary at the time simon
case a very serious allegations
um an email that was taken so seriously
went right to the top
of the tree in terms of palisades
and it must be pointed out that these
bullying allegations are strongly
refuted by the duchess of sussex she
claims she didn't bully anyone out of
the palace
this is a front page story it's made big
waves over here in the uk
because quite simply these are serious
allegations
megan who is a spokesperson for women
around
the world who who claims in her own
statement and has spoken very publicly
about
being the subject of bullying she's
talked about online bullying
and trolling and being bullied in the
media now having to fend off claims
that she in fact has been a bully so
it's
it's a big story over here the
suggestion here is that this was much
more than just a
clash of personalities megan perhaps
having a different
work ethic uh to what the palace is used
to i mean megan has been very vocal
about bullying that she has received
online
in the media so i think i think the word
is being used quite
deliberately accusing her of bullying
and
i think clearly there there is someone
who has an axe to grind they have a
grudge
and uh their timing is interesting uh to
say the least because of course
this bombshell uh comes just days before
the couple
uh will sit down and talk to oprah were
you silent
or were you silenced i just want to make
it clear to everybody
there is no subject that's off limit the
timing of the interview
is of course not a coincidence clearly
someone at the palace whether it's a
former aide a current aid
someone wants a different side of the
story to go out before harry and megan
have their chance to speak clearly this
interview has set
alarm bells ringing at the palace um
when when a royal sits down and does an
interview like this
historically it has just never bode well
diana's interview with panorama
ultimately was a disaster
and when prince charles sat down with
jonathan dimbleby he didn't have the
desired result that he wanted and more
recently
prince andrew's disastrous news night
interview so there is definitely
trepidation ahead of this interview i
think there are
a lot of courtiers who are very nervous
about the interview and
apprehensive about exactly what the
couple are going to say
and we know that race is going to be
something that oprah
has asked megan about we don't know what
megan is going to say but
that is the sort of thing that is going
to set
alarm bells ringing at buckingham palace
i personally do not think that
buckingham palace would have sanctioned
the um the release of this email this
this story that
run in the times quite simply no one
comes out of this
looking good this is a very public
airing
of the royal family's dirty linen i can
only imagine that the queen would be
um incredibly disappointed this is not
the sort of pr that she wants
for her family i think it's incredibly
unlikely that the palace
um is behind this clearly there is a
member of staff or a former member of
staff who
is disgruntled and who wants to have a
different
version of events put out there
you